[Music]
fans of the wachowski's sci-fi classic
have known for a while that the matrix
franchise is getting a fourth
installment what's more lana wachowski
is said to direct and keanu reeves
carrie anne moss and a slew of other
stars of the original movies will make
their glorious return in the matrix iv
the movie will also feature some brand
new additions to the cast from jessica
henwick and neil patrick harris to yaya
abdul mateen ii oh and if you're
expecting new cutting edge camera tricks
such as the original movie's
groundbreaking bullet time don't worry
henwick has already teased there will be
plenty to be excited about on that front
as well warner brothers just dropped a
heaping helping of matrix 4 data at
cinemacon proving once and for all that
the movie isn't just some plot by a
bunch of machines that use your hopes
and dreams as a battery with the
exception of the 1999 original the 2003
animated the animatrix and a bunch of
video games many installments and the
matrix franchise have a penchant for
alliterative titles the second and third
movies in the series both of which
premiered in 2003 were called the matrix
reloaded and the matrix revolutions and
even the 2001 documentary about the
making of the original movie is known as
the matrix revisited warner brothers has
now revealed that the matrix 4 will
follow the tradition and its official
title is the matrix resurrections
speculations about this title have
actually been going on for quite a while
to the point that slash film jokingly
predicted it way back in 2009 besides
giving huge credit to slash film for
nailing that one the name is pretty
fitting considering that it's
essentially resurrecting the matrix
franchise there's also the fact that
keanu reeves and carrie and mark are set
to return in resurrections and their
characters died pretty conclusively in
the matrix revolutions this means that
in one way or another the characters
will find their way back from beyond the
veil hopefully in a way that allows them
to re-enter the fray while already
wearing their iconic sunglasses the
title reveal incidentally also falls in
line with the screening leak that
dropped in june the anonymous switcher
accounts behind the leak also stated
that the matrix resurrections is
thematically close to the matrix
reloaded it remains to be seen whether
this is the case the title reveal of the
matrix resurrections would be exciting
news in its own right but as the
hollywood reporter notes warner brothers
also used their cinemacon platform to
screen the first trailer for the movie
as you'd expect the trailer which will
presumably drop online before long is
full of massively exciting mind-bending
stuff
reportedly the trailer shows reeves
character back in his everyman thomas
anderson mode suppressing his nagging
feeling that the world's slightly off
with a steady diet of blue pills and
sessions with his therapist there's a
curious meeting with moss's apparently
equally amnesiac character and an
encounter with abdul mateen's
suspiciously morpheus-like character cue
red pill martial arts training and
amazing neopowers which apparently allow
keanu to control missiles with his mind
this time if much of this seems very
reminiscent of the original the matrix
it's likely intentional because apart
from the usual what is the matrix
shenanigans there's clearly another
layer of existential terror lying
underneath the surface supposedly
there's a mirror shot that shows an
older and younger thomas neo and the
fact that pretty much everyone in the
world is terribly interested in their
phones might mean something awful as
well once this trailer officially drops
we'll be back with a video breaking it
all down with the easter eggs and small
details you know and love the matrix
resurrections is currently slated to
premiere on december 22nd
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the matrix are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one